Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
GET A ONCE-IN-LIFETIME CHANCE
TO PITCH THE SHARKS IN HOPES
OF GETTING AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESSES.
WE SAW A PROBLEM,
AND WE CAME UP WITH A SOLUTION.
WE'RE HERE
TO MAKE A DEAL.
IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WE INVESTED $700
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
TOTAL?
TOTAL.
Greiner: WOW.
YOU GUYS ARE
THE AMERICAN DREAM COME TRUE.
Narrator: ...THEY'RE READY
TO INVEST USING THEIR OWN MONEY.
I'D DO YOUR DEAL --
$200,000 FOR 20%.
Narrator: AND THEY'RE WILLING
TO FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF THE ACTION.
I'M GONNA MATCH
KEVIN'S OFFER.
WHEN I WAS 16 YEARS OLD,
I WAS A WARD
OF THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
I SPENT TWO YEARS LIVING
ON THE STREETS OF PHILADELPHIA,
AND BY 20, I DECIDED
THAT I WANTED
TO MAKE SOMETHING OF MYSELF.
I-I KNOW YOU.
I MEAN, YOU'RE A LEGEND.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
OUR MONTH-TO-MONTH GROWTH
HAS PLATEAUED.
I HATE WHEN I HEAR THAT.
THIS IS GOING TO END
SO BADLY!
THE IDEA IS LUDICROUS.
YOU KNOW THAT SCENE
IN THOSE MOVIES IN THE E.R.
WHERE THEY'RE BRINGING
THE PATIENT, AND THE
HEART IS SLOWLY...
[ IMITATES MONITOR BEEPING ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
PADDLES.
[ IMITATES ELECTRICITY BUZZING,
MONITOR BEEPING, FLATLINE ]
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
I'M STEPHANIE.
AND I'M BRETT.
AND WE'RE A HUSBAND AND WIFE
FROM FORT WORTH, TEXAS.
MWAH!
[ GIGGLES ]
WHEN WE FIRST HAD CHARLOTTE,
WE WERE SO EXCITED...
[ GIGGLES ]
...BUT AS HAPPENS,
THE SLEEPLESS NIGHTS STARTED.
OUT OF DESPERATION,
I CREATED SOMETHING
THAT HAD OUR DAUGHTER
SLEEPING THROUGH THE NIGHT
EVERY NIGHT.
STEPHANIE'S INVENTION
WAS LIFE-CHANGING.
WE KNEW IT WOULD HELP
OTHER PARENTS ACROSS THE WORLD,
SO WE LAUNCHED OUR BUSINESS.
THINGS WERE
MOVING ALONG GREAT,
AND WE WERE READY TO HAVE
ANOTHER BABY.
AFTER GETTING PREGNANT,
I STARTED EXPERIENCING PAIN,
AND WE WENT TO
THE HOSPITAL
AND FOUND OUT
THAT WE HAD LOST THE BABY.
THE DOCTORS HAD TOLD ME
THAT IF I HAD NOT GONE IN,
I WOULD HAVE DIED
WITHIN 24 HOURS.
[ Voice breaking ] TO CONTINUE
ON WITH BUSINESS AS USUAL
WAS IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME.
I HAD TO TELL MY CUSTOMERS,
"I NEED YOUR PATIENCE
AND UNDERSTANDING
BECAUSE I LOST A BABY."
AS SOON AS I SHARED THAT,
I WAS FLOODED
WITH THESE WOMEN
THAT HAD GONE THROUGH
WHAT I HAD GONE THROUGH.
IT REALLY HELPED ME HEAL,
AND THEN SOON,
WE FOUND OUT
WE WERE PREGNANT AGAIN.
EVERY CLOUD HAS
A SILVER LINING,
AND OUR SILVER LINING
WAS OUR LITTLE BOY, MAVERICK.
HI!
WE'VE TAKEN THE COMPANY
THIS FAR,
BUT WE REALLY NEED
THE SHARKS' INVOLVEMENT
TO REACH
OUR FULL POTENTIAL.
Brett:
WE HOPE THE SHARKS WILL SEE
HOW TRULY SPECIAL
THIS BUSINESS REALLY IS.
MWAH!
[ CHUCKLES ]
WHAT'S UP, SHARKS?
MY NAME IS BRETT PARKER.
AND I'M STEPHANIE PARKER,
AND WE'RE
FROM FORT WORTH, TEXAS.
OUR COMPANY IS
SLEEPING BABY,
AND WE'RE HERE SEEKING
AN INVESTMENT OF $200,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR
10% OF OUR COMPANY.
FOR NEW PARENTS, THE MOST
VALUABLE COMMODITY IS SLEEP.
YOU'LL DO ANYTHING TO GET
YOUR BABY TO SLEEP LONGER.
OUR PRODUCT IS
A SLEEP AND SANITY SAVER
FOR PARENTS AND BABIES
EVERYWHERE.
WHEN OUR DAUGHTER,
CHARLOTTE, WAS A NEWBORN,
WE PRACTICED
THE SWADDLE TECHNIQUE,
WHERE WE WRAPPED HER UP
LIKE A LITTLE BURRITO,
AND THE TIGHT AND COZY FIT
HELPED HER SLEEP
THROUGH THE NIGHT.
THIS OUR SON, MAVERICK.
[ CLICKS TONGUE ]
[ LAUGHS ]
HE'S ALL SNUG
IN A SWADDLE,
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
LIKE MOST BABIES,
EVENTUALLY THEY BREAK OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THEY START
SCRATCHING THEIR FACE,
WAKING THEMSELF UP,
AND THAT'S NEVER GOOD
FOR THE BABY OR THE PARENT.
WELL, OUR DAUGHTER...
[ CHUCKLES ]
...UH, AS SHE GOT OLDER,
BEGAN WAKING UP
EVERY 15 MINUTES.
WE WERE EXHAUSTED.
WE KNEW THAT WE HAD TO DO
SOMETHING
TO TRANSITION
OFF THE SWADDLE.
Stephanie: OUT OF DESPERATION
AND EXHAUSTION,
I SAT DOWN
AT MY LITTLE SEWING MACHINE,
AND THE FABULOUS
ZIPADEE-ZIP WAS BORN.
LIKE A SWADDLE, IT MIMICS
THE COZY, ENCLOSED ENVIRONMENT
OF THE WOMB,
BUT IT ALSO ALLOWS A BABY
TO PUSH UP AND ROLL OVER
AND WIGGLE AROUND
SAFELY AND FREELY.
I'LL SHOW YOU A LITTLE BIT
HOW IT WORKS.
SO, THIS IS OUR LITTLE SON,
MAVERICK, AGAIN,
SLEEPING IN
HIS ZIPADEE-ZIP.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND HE STARTLES,
AND AS YOU CAN SEE,
BECAUSE OF THE SLIGHT RESISTANCE
IN THE ARMS,
HE'S ABLE TO PUT HIMSELF
BACK TO SLEEP WITHOUT MY HELP.
AWW.
SO, WHEN OUR DAUGHTER TRIED
THE ZIPADEE-ZIP THE FIRST TIME,
SHE SLEPT 12 HOURS,
WHICH MEANS WE SLEPT 12 HOURS
THAT NIGHT.
SO, I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND SHOW YOU
A COUPLE OF
OUR ZIPADEE-ZIPS
SO YOU SEE
THE FABULOUS QUALITY.
SO, WHO STARTLED THE BABY
JUST TO MAKE A GREAT VIDEO?
ME.
AH.
THANK YOU.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I KNOW, RIGHT?
I SEE YOUR PRIORITIES
ARE IN ORDER. I LIKE THAT.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, GOSH."
WHAT'S YOURS GOT ON IT, KEVIN?
MONSTERS.
OKAY, SO WHY --
WHY DON'T YOU TELL US
HOW MANY OF THESE LITTLE
STRAIGHTJACKETS YOU'RE SELLING?
[ CHUCKLES ]
Brett: WE'VE SOLD A FEW.
WE'VE SOLD ABOUT 25,000.
WHAT DO YOU
SELL THEM FOR?
$34.95 TO $39.95.
Greiner: WHEN DID YOU START
SELLING THEM?
UH, TWO AND A HALF YEARS,
SO WE'VE SOLD A LITTLE OVER
$1 MILLION WORTH.
OH.
WOW.
DO YOU SELL THEM DIRECT?
DO YOU SELL THEM WHOLESALE?
100% OF OUR BUSINESS
IS THROUGH OUR OWN SITE.
Stephanie: ONLINE.
WOW.
ONLINE. WOW.
John: 100%?
100%.
YES.
GOOD FOR YOU.
Herjavec: VERY GOOD.
SO, HOW DID YOU GET THE WORD OUT
THERE ABOUT IT?
HOW DO PEOPLE KNOW
TO GET IT?
THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE
COMMUNITY OF MOMS
THAT WHEN THEIR BABIES
ARE SLEEPING, THEY TALK.
WE HAVE DONE NO MARKETING.
Brett: GUYS, WE WERE TRYING
TO MAKE $200 A MONTH
SO MY WIFE COULD STAY AT HOME
WITH THE BABY.
WE INVESTED $700
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
TOTAL?
TOTAL.
THAT'S IT.
BUILT, UH, A $500 WEBSITE,
GRABBED $200 OF THE FABRIC,
AND SAT THROUGH IT
TOGETHER.
AND WHEN IT WENT LIVE,
WE DID $200 IN FIVE MINUTES,
SHUT IT OFF,
AND MY -- MY WIFE SAID...
WOW.
Herjavec: [ LAUGHS ]
Stephanie:
OH, CRAP. [ LAUGHS ]
...MY WIFE SAID,
"WHAT AM I GONNA DO?"
John: WOW.
AND I SAID, "YOU'RE GONNA LEARN
HOW TO SEW!"
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, WHAT MAKES THE BABY FALL
ASLEEP IN THIS,
'CAUSE HE'S NOT TIGHT?
NO. I CAN TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF SCIENCE BEHIND IT.
SO, UM, A BABY, WHEN THEY'RE
STUCK IN THE WOMB
FOR A REALLY LONG TIME,
THEY'RE IN THAT LITTLE,
TINY BALL, RIGHT?
AND SO, WHEN THEY ARE OUT
OF THE WOMB, ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THERE'S THIS FREEDOM,
AND THEY HAVE SOMETHING CALLED
A MORO REFLEX.
A WHAT?
IT'S A STARTLE REFLEX SO THAT
WHEN A BABY PUTS THEIR ARMS OUT,
THEY KIND OF FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE FALLING,
AND SO THEY JOLT....
OH, WOW.
...AND JUST LIKE YOU SAW
RIGHT THERE.
AND SO, THEY NEED TO FEEL
THEIR EDGES,
AND IF THEY'RE ABLE TO FEEL
THEN THEY'RE ABLE
TO FALL BACK ASLEEP
A LOT MORE EFFICIENTLY.
SO, IT'S A WOMB-LIKE,
PROTECTIVE STATE.
EXACTLY.
OKAY, SO IF
I GAVE YOU $200,000,
COULD YOU QUADRUPLE
YOUR PRODUCTION?
IMMEDIATELY.
AND YOU KNOW WHICH SKUs
YOU WOULD DO THAT TO?
I WOULD DO IT
WITH MY NEW PRINTS
THAT I KNOW FOR A FACT
WILL SELL,
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
I HAVE ACTUALLY VETTED
THESE PRINTS
WITH ALL OF MY ONLINE,
UH, FOLLOWERS.
THEY VOTE ON THEM.
SO, THEY VOTE ON THEM.
WOW. CLEVER.
AND THEY CHOOSE
WHAT THEY WANT.
[ Voice breaking ]
I CANNOT TELL Y--
I CANNOT TELL YOU THE,
UM, COMMUNITY OF WOMEN THAT...
UM, IS PART OF OUR, UH --
PART OF OUR PROCESS.
IT'S JUST, UM,
IT'S -- IT'S MIND-BLOWING.
UM...
[ SIGHS ]
LAST -- LAST YEAR, WE, UM --
WE LOST OUR -- OUR BABY,
AND WE HAD AN INCREDIBLE
COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
THAT WERE WILLING TO BE THERE
FOR US AND, VICE VERSA, FOR THEM
IN TERMS OF JUST FEELING LIKE
THEY COULD GO TO OUR --
OUR SOCIAL-MEDIA PAGES AND --
AND SHARE SOME OF THEIR HEARTS.
AND SO, THERE'S
NO DUPLICATING THAT.
STEPH, I'M SO SORRY
ABOUT YOUR BABY.
YOU KNOW, WE -- IF --
IF THAT HADN'T HAPPENED,
WE WOULDN'T HAVE MAVERICK.
YEAH, SO...
SO, I AM SO GRATEFUL,
AND HE'S IN HIS ZIPADEE-ZIP
SLEEPING RIGHT NOW.
[ LAUGHS ] SO...
Greiner:
YOU KNOW, IT'S INTERESTING.
I HAVE FOUND THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS OF CREATING PRODUCT
AND DEALING WITH A LOT
OF DIFFERENT ENTREPRENEURS
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
REALLY PUTTING OUT GOOD
HAVE A LOT OF GOOD
COMING BACK TO THEM.
I THINK YOU'RE DOING
EVERYTHING RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
AN OFFER.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $200,000,
BUT I'D LIKE 25%
BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF HELP FROM ME
IN HELPING YOU TO BUILD
THE BRAND AND GET IT OUT THERE.
BUT I REALLY LIKE
THE PROOF OF CONCEPT.
THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE GRATEFUL,
BUT IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU,
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR SOME --
SOME OTHER THINGS.
DO YOU WANT
TO GO INTO RETAIL?
IS THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU'D LIKE TO DO,
OR DO YOU WANT TO KEEP THIS
AS A COMMUNITY ONLINE?
YOU KNOW, UH, A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU GUYS ASK,
WE NEED TO HAVE
DEFINITIVE ANSWERS.
I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT.
YOU NEED TO HAVE
THAT ANSWER CLEAR
BECAUSE I'M THE GUY WHO WANTS TO
TAKE IT TO RETAIL, RIGHT?
SURE.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT'S THE RIGHT ANSWER.
SURE.
YOU'RE MAKING A CLEAN --
Y-Y-YOU'RE GONNA BRING IN
MAYBE $1 MILLION THIS YEAR...
CORRECT.
...WITH NO HASSLE OF,
UH, DEALING WITH RETAILERS
SENDING IT BACK.
YOU MAY NOT
WANT TO GO TO RETAIL.
SURE.
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, THESE GUYS
WANT TO SQUEEZE YOU
WHEN YOU GO TO RETAIL.
WELL, THAT WOULD BE
MY VISION, TOO.
AND WE'RE
OF THAT MIND, TOO.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
WE'VE NEVER CROSSED THAT BRIDGE.
SO, L-LET ME CHIME IN HERE.
UM, MY FAMILY, WHEN THEY MOVED
TO NORTH AMERICA,
THEY BROUGHT A BUSINESS CALLED
KIDDIES TOGS WITH THEM.
THAT'S WHAT
MY GRANDFATHER STARTED,
AND THEY MADE EXACTLY
THIS CLOTHING -- IDENTICAL.
REALLY?
YEP.
THEY WERE IN EXISTENCE
WHEN WE COULD
MAKE THIS STUFF IN AMERICA
AT A COST
THAT WAS COMPETITIVE,
AND WHEN IT TRANSITIONED
TO ASIA, THEY GOT KILLED.
RETAIL IS A VERY DIFFICULT BEAST
TO MANAGE.
I THINK THIS CONNECTION
YOU'VE CREATED WITH
YOUR CUSTOMER BASE IS UNIQUE.
AND IT'S --
IT -- IT'S FROM THE HEART.
IT'S HARD TO LISTEN TO YOUR
STORY WITHOUT GETTING EMOTIONAL,
IT'S SO POWERFUL.
I'D DO YOUR DEAL, UM --
$200,000 FOR 20%.
STRAIGHT DEAL. I DO NOT WANT TO
SEE YOU DIE IN RETAIL.
I'M ABOUT TO FALL OVER.
John: NO ROYALTY FOREVER?
[ CHUCKLES ]
NO ROYALTIES?
O'Leary: NO, NO, THERE'S NO --
THERE'S NO ROYALTY.
THERE'S NO ROYALTIES.
MY OFFER IS STRAIGHT EQUITY.
I HAVE A CONNECTION
TO THIS BUSINESS.
I SHOULD PAY YOU
TO ACTUALLY TAKE
THAT DEAL, BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE A FIRST EVER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Cuban: OH, MY GOD.
EVER.
NO, YOU -- YOU -- THIS IS MY OLD
FAMILY BUSINESS ALL OVER AGAIN
EXCEPT WITH PEOPLE THAT HAVE
FIGURED IT OUT IN A NEW WORLD.
Brett:
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
SO, I'M GONNA MATCH
KEVIN'S OFFER.
WOW.
$200,000 FOR 20%.
AND ARE YOU
A RETAIL GUY?
I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO TRY IT, TEST IT.
IF IF DOESN'T WORK, WE'RE
GONNA STAY RIGHT WHERE WE ARE.
I'M STICKING.
AND WE HAVE YET
TO HEAR FROM MARK.
Cuban:
YOU GUYS DON'T NEED ME.
I MEAN, LOOK, YOU GUYS ARE
THE AMERICAN DREAM COME TRUE...
THANK YOU.
...BECAUSE EVERYBODY OUT THERE
NOW KNOWS
THAT YOUR BACK CAN BE
AGAINST THE WALL,
YOU CAN SUFFER PERSONAL TRAGEDY,
AND WITH $700,
YOU CAN BE STANDING RIGHT THERE
AND ALREADY HAVE
A GREAT BUSINESS IN PLACE
AND GET ALL THESE OFFERS.
THANK YOU.
WELL...
SO, WHILE I'M OUT,
I CAN'T APPLAUD YOU ENOUGH.
YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING.
Stephanie: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THAT MEANS A LOT.
YOU KNOW, AS MARK SAID,
YOU'RE THE PROOF.
ALL YOU NEED IS DRIVE,
YOU NEED AMBITION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
YOU NEED TO SPEND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS,
AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE THIS IS REALLY
THE O'LEARY FAMILY BUSINESS,
WHICH I NEVER KNEW, SO...
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DIDN'T KNOW
HE HAD A FAMILY!
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, ON THIS ONE...I-I'M OUT.
BUT YOU'VE GOT THREE OFFERS.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO?
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU.
WHAT AN OPPORTUNITY.
ALL THE OFFERS
ARE EXTREMELY GENEROUS.
MY QUESTION TO YOU, DAYMOND,
IS THIS --
WE UNDERSTAND THAT YOU PROBABLY
HAVE THE MANUFACTURING
THAT YOU COULD
HELP US OUT WITH, CORRECT?
SURE. OF COURSE.
UM, AND...WE DON'T WANT
TO BE OVERLY GREEDY,
BUT FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM,
THIS IS OUR BABY.
BUT WITHOUT GOING
BACK AND FORTH,
WE WOULD DO
THE 15% FOR $200,000,
AND WE WOULD DO IT TODAY.
[ SIGHS ]
WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
Narrator: TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
STEPHANIE AND BRETT HAVE
THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR BABY SLEEPWEAR
COMPANY, SLEEPING BABY.
THEY'VE COUNTERED 15%
TO DAYMOND'S OFFER
OF $200,000
FOR 20% OF THE COMPANY.
WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
[ SIGHS ]
I WOULD NORMALLY WANT 33%.
I WILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO ON THIS.
GOING DOWN ANY LOWER WILL BE
CHALLENGING BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY,
THERE'S A LOT OF IN-KIND THINGS
THAT COME WITH IT
BECAUSE WHEN I HAVE A STAFF,
I'M STILL PAYING THEM,
NOT -- NOT PUTTING THE COST
ONTO YOU.
I HAVE TO STICK TO MY NUMBER,
AND I'M SORRY.
I NORMALLY WOULD BE 33%.
I REALLY WANT
TO TAKE THIS RIDE WITH YOU,
BUT I HAVE TO STICK AT 20%.
LET ME
ASK YOU THIS --
DO YOU WANT TO PARTNER
ANOTHER SHARK IN THIS PROCESS?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
OKAY.
YOU GOT A DEAL, BUDDY.
BANG.
WOW.
CONGRATS, GUYS.
WHOO! AH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
Greiner: MY CONGRATULATIONS.
John: I LIKE THAT.
I WAS WORRIED, TOO.
"YOU WANT A PARTNER?"
"NO."
"GOOD! ME NEITHER."
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
I LOVE THAT YEE-HAW.
[ CHUCKLES ]
[ CHUCKLES ] YEAH.
OH, MY GOSH.
I'M GONNA PASS OUT.
[ LAUGHS ]
YEAH.
WE KNEW THAT WE WANTED
TO DO BUSINESS WITH DAYMOND.
YEAH, HE KNOWS HIS STUFF
IN THAT INDUSTRY,
AND SO WE'RE SO EXCITED
THAT WE HAVE SOMEONE
THAT'S BEEN THERE, DONE THAT,
AND CAN LEAD US THROUGH THE NEXT
MILLION YEARS OF ZIPADEE-ZIP.
[ CHUCKLES ]
Corcoran:
TODAY, WE'RE AT TARGET TO SEE
OUR BRAND-NEW
"SHARK TANK" DISPLAY
WITH SIX OF OUR
"SHARK TANK" PRODUCTS.
AND WE'VE INVITED OUR SIX
GREAT ENTREPRENEURS HERE
TO SEE THE DISPLAY
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME.
I'M SO EXCITED FOR THEM.
I'M EXCITED FOR US.
I MEAN, THIS IS TARGET.
[ CHEERS ]
HEY!
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
FROM MY END, WE HAVE KaZAM,
WE HAVE LOLLALAND, U-LACE,
KISSTIXX,
AND WE HAVE MONKEY MAT.
AND I'VE BROUGHT IN
RYAN'S BARKERY,
NOW KNOWN AS RY'S RUFFERY.
A THOUSAND STORES
ACROSS THE U.S.
WITH THIS
BEAUTIFUL DISPLAY.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE
A MAGICAL DREAM, RIGHT?
SEEING MY PRODUCT AT A TARGET
PRETTY MUCH TOOK MY BREATH AWAY.
Lugo:
THIS IS WHAT I HAD ENVISIONED
BEFORE I WENT ON "SHARK TANK,"
AND NOW, JUST A YEAR LATER,
IT'S HAPPENING.
THIS REALLY SHOWS YOU
THE POWER OF "SHARK TANK"
AND THE KIND OF HUGE DEAL
A SHARK CAN BRING TO THE TABLE.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
PRETTY MUCH ALL OF YOU GUYS
STARTED IN A BASEMENT,
A KITCHEN, A GARAGE.
YOU GUYS HAVE HIT
THE BIG TIME.
"SHARK TANK" PROVES THAT IF
YOU HAVE A GREAT IDEA,
AND YOU'RE WILLING
TO WORK LIKE CRAZY,
YOUR DREAM CAN COME TRUE.
I DIDN'T HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE.
I WAS LIVING
IN A FRIEND'S HOUSE.
SINCE "SHARK TANK,"
THE FUTURE IS TRULY BRIGHT.
Turich: "SHARK TANK" HAS
OPENED UP SO MANY DOORS FOR US,
AND MONKEY MAT'S BECOMING
A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
Hanna: IT'S SURREAL.
WE FINALLY HAVE
THE BRAND RECOGNITION
TO SELL THROUGH
AT A PLACE LIKE TARGET.
Buonomo: BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
WE ONLY HAD $70,000 IN SALES.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS LATER,
WE'RE APPROACHING $2 MILLION.
Cuban: WE DID THE MATH.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
ALL SIX COMPANIES COMBINED --
ABOUT $1.3 MILLION
IN SALES.
POST "SHARK TANK" --
$7.7 MILLION IN SALES.
THAT'S A 500% INCREASE.
"SHARK TANK" ON THREE.
ANYBODY WHO TELLS YOU
THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS NOT ALIVE AND WELL
HAS NEVER WATCHED
"SHARK TANK."
WE SEND A MESSAGE
EVERY FRIDAY NIGHT ON ABC
THAT THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS ALIVE AND WELL.
Together:
THANK YOU, MARK AND BARBARA!
[ CHEERING ]
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A UNIQUE
CONCEPT IN MEN'S GROOMING.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL ELLIOT.
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA,
AND MY BUSINESS IS
HAMMER & NAILS.
I'M SEEKING $200,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
SHARKS, THERE ARE
MILLIONS OF GUYS LIKE ME
WHO GO TO NAIL SALONS
FOR MANICURES AND PEDICURES,
BUT WE DO SO RELUCTANTLY.
MM-HMM.
IT'S NOT THE SERVICE
THAT WE HATE SO MUCH,
IT'S THE ENVIRONMENT.
NAIL SALONS WEREN'T DESIGNED TO
APPEAL TO MEN'S SENSIBILITIES.
WOMEN ARE
THEIR DESIRED CUSTOMERS,
AND US GUYS KNOW THAT.
WE FEEL THAT
THE MOMENT WE WALK IN THE DOOR.
SO I CREATED HAMMER & NAILS --
THE NAIL SHOP FOR GUYS.
IN MY SHOP,
GUYS FEEL RIGHT AT HOME
WITH LOW LIGHTING AND OVERSIZED
LEATHER CHAIRS JUST LIKE THIS,
WEARING HIGH-END HEADPHONES,
WATCHING PREMIUM PROGRAMMING
ON THEIR OWN PERSONAL
32-INCH FLAT-SCREEN TVs.
HAMMER & NAILS
IS MAN-CAVE NIRVANA.
MY GOAL IS
TO GROW HAMMER & NAILS
ACROSS THE U.S.
AND THE WORLD.
WITH AN INVESTMENT
FROM YOU SHARKS,
I CAN REACH MY GOAL,
AND TOGETHER,
WE CAN PUT THE "MAN"
IN "MANICURE."
ROBERT, I'D LOVE
TO HAVE YOU COME DOWN.
I WOULD LIKE
TO COME DOWN.
SIT IN THIS AMAZING CHAIR.
Cuban:
AW, I WANTED TO DO IT.
Herjavec: OH, PLEASE.
KICK HIM OUT.
OH, WOW.
Elliot:
SEE, THERE YOU GO.
THIS IS VERY COMFORTABLE,
MICHAEL.
THERE YOU GO.
Greiner: IT'S CLEVER.
THANK YOU.
HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
WELL, I WAS IN DESPERATE NEED
OF A PEDICURE.
IT WAS LIKE A CRIME SCENE
DOWN THERE.
Cuban: [ LAUGHS ]
SO, I GO TO THIS NAIL SALON.
AND I'M SITTING THERE,
IT'S FILLED WITH WOMEN,
AND I JUST FELT
LIKE A FISH OUT OF WATER.
AND THAT WAS
MY "AHA" MOMENT.
WHAT WAS SURPRISING TO ME
WAS HOW MANY OF MY WELL-GROOMED
GUY FRIENDS...
THAT IS SO GOOD.
...ADMITTED THAT THEY
HAVE NEVER HAD
A MANICURE OR PEDICURE BEFORE --
IT WAS SOMETHING UNMANLY.
O'Leary:
OKAY, GIVE US SOME NUMBERS.
YEAH, LET'S GO INTO
THE BUSINESS.
DO YOU HAVE
A LOCATION ALREADY?
OH, ABSOLUTELY.
SO, I OPENED HAMMER & NAILS
SEVEN MONTHS AGO.
SO FAR,
WE'VE GENERATED $150,000.
WE'LL DO ANOTHER $100,000
IN THE NEXT FIVE MONTHS.
SO, WE'LL DO $250,000
OUR FIRST YEAR.
THAT WAS GREAT.
THANK YOU, MICHAEL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, NATASHA.
WHAT DO YOU CHARGE
FOR A, UH, MANICURE/PEDICURE?
PRICES RANGE FROM $23
UP TO AS HIGH AS $125.
John:
DO YOU DO ANYTHING ELSE,
SUCH AS TAILORING
OR ANYTHING ELSE THERE?
WAXING?
NO.
WE ONLY DO MANICURES
AND PEDICURES, SOME MASSAGES...
OKAY.
...AND THIS IS WHY --
I THINK BY CREATING SERVICES
LIKE FACIALS, WAXING,
THINGS LIKE THAT,
SUDDENLY HAMMER & NAILS
BECOMES A SALON.
I WANT HAMMER & NAILS TO BE
WHAT IT IS.
I WANT TO PROTECT THE BRAND
AND STAY IN OUR LANE
AND BE THE BEST AT IT,
BECAUSE 3,000 GUYS
HAVE WALKED THROUGH MY DOOR --
MILLIONAIRES TO THE GUYS
THAT WORK AT THE CABLE COMPANY.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
WELL, I -- LOOK,
WHEN I WAS 16 YEARS OLD,
I WAS A KID IN THE SYSTEM.
I WAS A WARD
OF THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
I SPENT MY JUNIOR YEAR
OF HIGH SCHOOL
LIVING IN A YOUTH SHELTER.
BY 18, I WAS
LITERALLY ON THE STREETS.
I SPENT TWO YEARS LIVING
ON THE STREETS OF PHILADELPHIA,
AND BY 20, I DECIDED
THAT I WANTED
TO MAKE SOMETHING OF MYSELF.
SO, I SAVED UP MY MONEY,
AND I DECIDED TO PUBLISH
THE VERY FIRST HIP-HOP MAGAZINE
ON MARCH 15, 1988.
I WENT FROM HOMELESS TO BE--
WHAT WAS IT CALLED?
IT WAS CALLED KRUSH --
K-R-U-S-H.
THE VERY NEXT YEAR,
I TOOK $250,
I CREATED A LOCAL
HIP-HOP MUSIC-VIDEO SHOW
CALLED "KRUSH RAP,"
AND I SELF-SYNDICATED IT
TO 20 MARKETS.
I BECAME THE DIRECTOR
OF SPECIAL PROJECTS
FOR THIS MAGAZINE
CALLED THE SOURCE,
WHICH WAS, AT THAT POINT,
THE ROLLING STONE OF HIP-HOP.
John: THE SOURCE?
THE SOURCE.
I-I KNOW YOU.
I MEAN, YOU'RE A LEGEND.
I MEAN...
THANK YOU.
KEEP GOING. THE STORY'S GOOD,
SO -- YOU'RE ENTERTAINING.
YEAH, THE STORY'S GREAT.
WELL, I WAS SORT OF
BURNED OUT ON HIP-HOP
AND DECIDED TO MOVE
TO CALIFORNIA.
I DECIDED I WAS GONNA
WRITE MOVIES, OF ALL THINGS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, LITERALLY,
I WENT TO A BOOKSTORE,
I BOUGHT A BOOK
ON SCREENWRITING --
Herjavec:
DID YOU WRITE A SCREENPLAY?
OH, BOY, DID I.
13 MONTHS LATER,
I SOLD MY VERY FIRST SCRIPT
TO 20th CENTURY FOX.
FOUR YEARS LATER,
IT WAS THE MOVIE "BROWN SUGAR."
MOST RECENTLY,
I HAD A FILM IN THEATERS
CALLED "JUST WRIGHT."
IT STARRED QUEEN LATIFAH.
MY FILMS TO DATE
HAVE GENERATED $118 MILLION
AT THE BOX OFFICE.
YOU KNOW,
YOUR STORY IS FASCINATING.
FASCINATING.
THANK YOU.
MY PLAN IS TWO THINGS --
I WANT TO FRANCHISE
THIS BUSINESS.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS COULD BE
THE STARBUCKS OF MEN'S
NAIL SHOPS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
I BELIEVE THAT, AND, TWO --
I MEAN, YOU CAN SAY, "I BELIEVE,
I BELIEVE" ALL YOU WANT...
NO, BUT LISTEN, KEVIN,
IT'S NOT ABOUT --
...BUT THE ONLY THING
THAT SPEAKS THE TRUTH
TO A FRANCHISEE
IS CASH FLOW.
NO, LISTEN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO KNOW --
CASH FLOW.
AND I UNDE--
KEVIN, I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT HERE'S WHAT I KNOW --
BECAUSE I --
I LIKE IT WHEN I SAY THAT.
YES, YOU DO.
I'M NOT TRYING TO --
IN OTHER WORDS,
SOMEBODY COME HERE
AND SAYS, "HOW MUCH MONEY AM I
GONNA MAKE IN THE FIRST YEAR,"
AND YOU SAY,
"YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE."
IT COMES DOWN
TO PROOF OF CONCEPT.
ABSOLUTELY.
SO, MICHAEL,
LET THE NUMBERS TALK.
SURE.
$250,000 FORECAST
FOR THIS YEAR --
HOW MUCH MONEY
ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE?
WELL, I WILL SAY THIS --
UH-OH.
I -- NO, I'LL -- I DIDN'T GO
INTO THIS PARTICULAR BUSINESS
BELIEVING THAT IN MY FIRST YEAR,
I'LL BE PROFITABLE.
SO, YOU'RE
GONNA BREAK EVEN?
I WILL BREAK EVEN.
IN FACT, LAST MONTH,
WE DID 25% MORE IN REVENUE,
AND WE DID BREAK EVEN.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU
JUST KEEP IT FOR YOURSELF?
WHY WOULD I NOT
FRANCHISE THE BUSINESS?
YEAH.
THERE'S MUCH MORE MONEY TO BE
MADE FRANCHISING THIS BUSINESS.
NO.
WE'LL DISAGREE ON THAT
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GOT IT,
AND YOU'RE
AHEAD OF THE CURVE,
GET TO THE POINT
WHERE IT IS SO PROFITABLE,
THE FRANCHISEES
WILL PAY WHATEVER
AS OPPOSED TO YOUR HAVING
TO CONVINCE THE FRANCHISEES.
YOU'RE PUTTING THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
SO, I THINK THAT THE
HAMMER & NAILS IS REALLY CLEVER,
BUT I HAVE NO IDEA
IF GUYS WOULD GO TO THAT OR NOT.
I DON'T THINK
THAT I COULD EVEN JUDGE
WHETHER OR NOT THIS BUSINESS
WOULD MAKE ME MY MONEY BACK,
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
Herjavec:
I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
THANK YOU.
I -- I MEAN,
I REALLY DO.
I MEAN, I'M -- I'M SITTING HERE,
I'M THINKING,
"WHY AREN'T THERE MORE OF THESE
SALONS OUT THERE FOR GUYS?"
BUT I REALLY DIDN'T LIKE
YOUR ANSWER TO MARK
BECAUSE
THE ONLY GOOD ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION
THAT MARK ASKED YOU,
WHICH IS "WHY DON'T YOU
JUST DO IT ON YOUR OWN?"
IS, "I DON'T HAVE
THE CAPITAL.
"I PUT EVERY PENNY TOGETHER
TO OPEN UP ONE STORE,
"AND I'M PROVING A CONCEPT,
AND THAT'S WHY
I HAVE TO FRANCHISE"...
RIGHT.
..."IF I WANT TO GROW."
I APPRECIATE THE MANICURE,
BUT I'M OUT.
OKAY.
O'Leary: SO, MICHAEL, YOU'RE
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF YEARS
FROM EVEN GETTING ANYBODY
TO SIGN FOR A FRANCHISE LICENSE.
AT SOME POINT, YOU
HAVE TO TELL ME WHAT THE
STABILIZED NUMBERS ARE
FOR A TWO-
TO THREE-YEAR PERIOD.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH YOU TRY
AND SELL THE VISION --
AND YOU'RE VERY GOOD AT IT --
IN THE END,
AS WE KNOW IN THE SHARK TANK,
THE NUMBERS RULE.
THEY ALWAYS
DICTATE THE TRUTH.
YOUR BUSINESS
DOESN'T MAKE MONEY,
AND I DO NOT BELIEVE.
SO, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANKS FOR CONSIDERING.
SO, I APPLAUD YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO
IN REGARDS TO
BRINGING BACK STYLE
AND TEACHING MEN
SOME MANNERS.
I USED TO BE A MEMBER
OF A PLACE IN NEW YORK
CALLED JOHN ALLAN --
A VERY SIMILAR PLACE.
YEAH.
I LIKE THE CONCEPT.
MY CHALLENGE IS THIS --
I BELIEVE
IF YOU HAVE A CUSTOMER,
YOU HAVE TO
UPSELL THE CUSTOMER,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE SELLING
AN EXPERIENCE LIKE THIS.
YOU GO TO SOMEPLACE
LIKE A JOHN ALLAN,
THEY HAVE FINE SUITS,
THEY HAVE A-A BAR.
ALSO, THAT WOULD BE
HARDER TO DUPLICATE
FOR A FRANCHISE OWNER
IF THEY TRY TO KNOCK YOU OFF.
I DON'T SEE
ALL OF THAT HERE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
LISTENING AND CONSIDERING.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK, MICHAEL.
Herjavec: YEAH, GOOD LUCK.
YEAH, CONGRATS
ON YOUR SUCCESSES.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
John: AND THANK YOU --
THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU'VE DONE FOR HIP-HOP.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
Herjavec: I THINK
YOU BROUGHT UP A GREAT POINT
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO BE
KNOCKED OFF AS A FRANCHISE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I WAS SURPRISED
KEVIN DIDN'T BRING IT UP.
OH, YEAH.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST CHAIRS
WITH SOME PEOPLE DOING NAILS.
O'Leary: I DON'T THINK
IT'S GONNA BREAK EVEN EVER.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK --
IT'S GOING TO ZERO.
Elliot: I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE TIME WHEN ALL OF THE SHARKS,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
KICK THEMSELVES AND GO,
"OH, MY GOD. HE DID IT."
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN,
SO...WATCH.
Narrator:
NEXT UP ARE RECENT COLLEGE GRADS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
A BETTER WAY TO STAY RECHARGED.
SHARKS,
MY NAME IS BILL SHUEY.
I AM THE CO-FOUNDER
AND C.E.O. OF AMBER.
AND MY NAME'S KYLE BYRD.
I'M HEAD OF PRODUCTS
AND A CO-FOUNDER AT AMBER.
SHARKS, TODAY WE ARE
RAISING $200,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% STAKE
WITHIN AMBER.
SHARKS, HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE YOU BEEN AT AN AIRPORT
AND HAD YOUR PHONE
TRAGICALLY DIE IN YOUR ARMS?
YOU KNOW OUR PAIN
ALL TOO WELL.
THE FACT IS
WE DIDN'T WANT TO WALK AROUND
WITH CHARGERS
IN OUR POCKETS
OR GIVE OUR PHONES
TO BARTENDERS
TO CHARGE OUR PHONES
IN A PUBLIC SPACE.
WE SAW A PROBLEM,
AND WE CAME UP WITH A SOLUTION.
SHARKS, AMBER IS
A MOBILE-PHONE CHARGING STATION
THAT IS COMPLETELY FREE
TO USE.
WE SECURE YOUR DEVICE
IN ONE OF OUR SEVEN COMPARTMENTS
USING BIOMETRIC SCANNING,
NAMELY FINGERPRINT SCANNING.
WE MADE IT
SUPER, SUPER SIMPLE.
LET'S SHOW YOU
HOW IT WORKS.
SIMPLY WALK UP,
SCAN THEIR FINGERPRINT...
...CHOOSE ONE OF
THE AVAILABLE COMPARTMENTS...
AND WHENEVER THEY'RE DONE,
THEY SIMPLY
RE-SCAN THEIR FINGER
AND ONE OF THE DOORS
WILL UNLOCK.
WE REALIZE THAT AMBER
WASN'T JUST A FREE, SECURE WAY
FOR PEOPLE TO CHARGE
THEIR PHONES IN A PUBLIC SPACE
BUT COULD ALSO DRIVE REVENUE
FOR VENUES
BY KEEPING PEOPLE
AROUND LONGER
AND HEIGHTENING
THE OVERALL CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
WE WANT TO PUT AMBER
IN BARS, RESTAURANTS, GYMS,
MOVIE THEATERS, ARENAS --
REALLY ANYWHERE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
SHARKS, BY SECURING
AN INVESTMENT TODAY,
WE CAN MAKE OUR FIRST BIG PUSH
INTO SEEING AMBER
IN VENUES
ACROSS THE NATION.
NOW, WHO WANTS
TO SECURE A DEAL WITH AMBER?
SO, IS THE PRODUCT
SHIPPING?
SO, WE ARE PRE-REVENUE.
I LOVE THAT WORD,
"PRE-REVENUE."
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE JUST GRADUATED
A FEW WEEKS AGO FROM COLLEGE.
WHERE'D YOU GO TO SCHOOL?
JAMES MADISON UNIVERSITY
IN VIRGINIA.
Herjavec: BILL,
WALK ME THROUGH THE PREMISE.
YOU WALK INTO A BAR.
SURE.
I'M A BAR OWNER.
YOU'RE A BAR OWNER.
HOW MUCH ARE YOU GONNA
CHARGE ME?
SO, WE WILL EITHER
CHARGE YOU $2,000 OUTRIGHT
FOR THE UNIT,
OR YOU CAN LEASE IT
EITHER ON A SIX-, NINE-MONTH --
AND SO I BUY IT FOR $2,000,
THAT'S IT.
SURE.
THERE'S NO MORE REVENUE
FOR YOU.
OR -- OR YOU CAN GET IT
RIGHT ON YOUR WALL
FOR $150 RIGHT THERE, AND
IT'S -- IT'S A MONTHLY $150.
IT'S A CONVENIENCE
FOR THE BAR,
BUT IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THEY HAVE TO HAVE, SO --
WELL, SO -- SO ACTUALLY,
RIGHT NOW,
PEOPLE ARE CHARGING THEIR PHONES
IN BARS, RIGHT?
THEY'RE GIVING THEM
TO BARTENDERS,
TO WAITRESSES AND WAITERS.
THAT'S A LIABILITY.
IT'S LIKE, "HEY,
CAN I GET MY PHONE?"
WELL, THAT WAITER OR WAITRESS
MAY HAVE LEFT,
GOTTEN OFF WORK,
AND NOW THEY HAVE A LOST PHONE.
John:
GUYS, YOU SAID A DOOR LOCKS.
I DIDN'T SEE A DOOR LOCK.
SO, THE LOCKS IN HERE
IS WHAT WE'RE USING FOR TESTING.
WE'RE ACTUALLY CURRENTLY,
UM, SOURCING OUR LOCKS
THROUGH MASTER LOCK.
OKAY, SO THERE WILL BE
A DOOR ON THERE?
YEAH, YEAH.
YES.
BILL, HAVE YOU TESTED
THE FINGERPRINT SCANNER?
WE HAVE. WE TEST IT ALL
ON THE BACK END.
'CAUSE I'M IN
THE CYBER-SECURITY SPACE.
RIGHT.
AND HERE'S WHAT I KNOW
ABOUT FINGERPRINT SCANNERS --
THEY CAN BE VERY FINICKY...
VERY.
...EXCEPT FOR
THE VERY, VERY HIGH-END ONES.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO YOU,
THE IDEA OF YOU WALKING UP ONCE,
PUTTING YOUR FINGER IN THERE,
AND IT RECOGNIZING YOU,
AND THE DOOR COMING DOWN
IS LUDICROUS.
WE HAVE
A BIG SECURITY CENTER.
THE FINGERPRINT SCANNER
THAT WE PAY
FOR PEOPLE TO GET INTO
THAT CENTER
WAS WELL, WELL OVER $50,000.
Y-- THERE'S NO WAY,
FOR THAT PRICE POINT,
YOU'RE GONNA BUY
A FINGERPRINT SCANNER
THAT'S GONNA WORK
THAT QUICKLY.
RIGHT, SO...SO --
HERE'S HOW IT'S GONNA WORK --
SOMEONE'S GONNA COME UP,
THEY'RE GONNA GO ONCE,
THEY'RE GONNA GO TWICE,
THEY'RE GONNA GO
THREE TIMES.
AND THEN THEY'RE GONNA PULL IT
OFF THE WALL. [ CHUCKLES ]
YEAH, AND I WAS GONNA SAY --
SO THE -- SO THE --
AND -- AND THIS IS BEFORE
THEY'VE HAD SOMETHING TO DRINK.
TELL US HOW MUCH YOU'VE
INVESTED, RIGHT,
BECAUSE YOU'VE
GOT TO BUILD PROTOTYPES.
SO, ON OUR COLLEGE BUDGETS,
UH, UH, WE ARE SITTING,
UM...
[ CLICKS TONGUE ]
I THINK
WE'RE RIGHT AROUND $11,000.
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE A UNIT?
RIGHT NOW WE CAN MAKE THE UNIT
FOR $1,000 WITH --
OH!
O'Leary: $1,000?
THIS IS GOING TO END
SO BADLY!
THAT IS
SUCH A BAD BUSINESS.
WHAT ARE YOU --
YOU'RE SAYING --
OH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU'RE SAYING THE COST OF IT
TO BUY IS $2,000, RIGHT?
THEY SAID $2,000.
OH, IT'S, UH -- IT'S $150
A MONTH OR $2,000 OUTRIGHT.
WHY WOULD A BAR
PAY YOU $2,000
WHEN YOU GO TO THE AIRPORT,
THOSE GUYS WHO HAVE
THE BIG CHARGERS,
THEY ISSUE IT FOR FREE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DO
THEIR ADVERTISING?
RIGHT.
WHY WOULDN'T A BAR PUT ONE
OF THOSE FREE DEVICES
BEHIND THE BAR?
Greiner: I MEAN, WHY DOES
ANYBODY REALLY NEED THIS?
I THINK THERE'S SO MANY
PERSONAL CHARGING DEVICES,
AND ACTUALLY,
I'M IN THE SPACE RIGHT NOW.
SURE.
WE'RE CREATING SOMETHING THAT IS
LIGHT-YEARS AHEAD OF THIS.
I'M OUT.
Cuban:
THE COST IS HORRIBLE, GUYS.
I MEAN, YOU'VE
GOT TO GET THIS DOWN
UNDER $100 TO EVEN BE --
AND THAT'S -- AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
UM, IT'S JUST
THE FACT OF THE CAPITAL...
BUT YOU'RE
SO FAR AWAY, RIGHT?
...TO GET TO THAT POINT.
AND I FEEL BAD
'CAUSE YOU'VE PUT IN A LOT
OF BLOOD, SWEAT, AND TEARS.
WAIT, WAIT. NO SWEAT AND TEARS,
JUST BLOOD IN THE WATER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BLOOD.
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD A LOT
OF INTEREST FROM FESTIVALS,
UM, AND, SAY, LARGER-SCALE
VENUES -- CONVENTIONS.
SO, WE ACTUALLY -- WE --
WE DEVELOPED A PRODUCT,
LIKE, PUTTING IT ON A STAND,
UM, AND HAVING, SAY, 14 UNITS.
Cuban: LOOK, WHENEVER YOU HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE,
ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU DON'T WANT TO DO
IS CREATE A REASON FOR THEM
TO CONGREGATE IN ONE SPOT
WAITING FOR SOMETHING.
ALL YOU'RE DOING
IS CREATING MORE LINES.
AND THEN, THE FINGER SCANNER --
SOMEONE'S WET, SOMEONE'S GRIMY.
YOU'RE AT A FESTIVAL -- IT'S NOT
GONNA BE A CLEAN ENVIRONMENT.
THIS IS DEFINITELY NOT FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
O'Leary: THERE'S ONLY ONE ANSWER
TO THIS --
I HAVE TO HIRE YOU BOTH
SO I CAN FIRE YOU.
THIS IS SO HORRIBLE.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS HAS ANY
CHANCE OF SURVIVING AND WORKING?
I HATE THIS SO MUCH,
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
IT'S ONE OF THE WORST IDEAS
I'VE EVER SEEN. I'M OUT.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO INTEREST
IN THIS BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
Shuey: SO, WE DO HAVE
COMPETITION.
THERE ARE A FEW
COMPANIES OUT NOW --
Cuban: YEAH, THERE'S
A LOT OF COMPETITORS.
RIGHT.
Herjavec:
YOUR BIGGEST COMPETITOR IS FREE.
YOU'VE COME OUT
WITH AN INCREDIBLY
ELEGANT SOLUTION TO FREE.
LOOK, I'M OUT.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
THANK YOU GUYS VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
I THINK THAT WAS
THE SHORTEST PITCH.
IT'S THE WORST PITCH,
THAT'S WHY.
IT'S HORRIBLE.
I THOUGHT YOU PUT
YOUR GLASS THERE AND FILL IT UP.
HEY, HE LEFT HIS PHONE!
[ LAUGHTER ]
Shuey: THE COST WAS AN ISSUE,
THE SECURITY WAS AN ISSUE.
I KNOW IT WORKS.
WE'VE TESTED IT A MILLION TIMES.
I MEAN, I WOULD PROBABLY
GO RAIL HERJAVEC IN THE TEETH.
I MEAN, IT -- THAT'S NOT...
WOW. [ CHUCKLES ]
THAT'S RUDE.
DUDE, SHE WANTED ME TO BE
HONEST, I'M BEING HONEST.
[ CHUCKLES ] OH, COME ON.
UM...
Narrator:
NEXT UP ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WITH WHAT THEY BELIEVE
IS A BETTER VERSION
OF A COMMON WARDROBE STAPLE.
HI, SHARKS. I'M DAVID.
AND I'M RANDY.
OUR COMPANY IS BOMBAS,
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
SEEKING $200,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR A 5% EQUITY STAKE.
BOMBAS ARE
ATHLETIC LEISURE SOCKS
ENGINEERED TO LOOK BETTER,
FEEL BETTER,
AND WITH A MISSION
TO HELP THOSE IN NEED.
THE MASS-MARKET ATHLETIC SOCK
HASN'T CHANGED IN DECADES --
SAME BASIC COLORS,
SAME STYLES,
SAME CARDBOARD FEEL --
UNTIL NOW.
WE SPENT TWO YEARS
ON RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
AND CAME UP WITH
SEVEN SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE ATHLETIC SOCK.
THE RESULT IS
THE MOST THOUGHTFULLY DESIGNED
AND COMFORTABLE PAIR OF SOCKS
YOU'LL EVER WEAR.
BUT THE STORY OF BOMBAS
GOES WAY BEYOND
REENGINEERING
THE ATHLETIC SOCK.
WE LEARNED THAT SOCKS
ARE THE NUMBER-ONE
MOST REQUESTED CLOTHING ITEM
AT HOMELESS SHELTERS.
THAT REALLY STUCK WITH US,
SO FOR EVERY PAIR OF SOCKS
WE SELL, WE DONATE A PAIR.
SO, WE HOPE YOU'LL JOIN US
TO MAKE BETTER SOCKS
FOR A BETTER WORLD.
WE BROUGHT SOME SOCKS WITH US
TODAY FOR YOU GUYS TO TRY ON.
THANK YOU.
SURE. ABSOLUTELY.
HERE YOU GO.
DO I GET THESE?
THOSE TWO.
THANK YOU.
THESE TWO ARE FOR YOU.
SURE.
THANK YOU, SIR.
APPRECIATE IT.
SURE.
Heath: WE'D LIKE TO TAKE
A QUICK MOMENT WHILE YOU'RE
TRYING THEM ON
TO TAKE YOU THROUGH OUR
SEVEN SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS.
WE STARTED
WITH PERUVIAN PIMA COTTON.
THIS IS A NATURAL FIBER
THAT WICKS MOISTURE, BREATHES,
STAYS WARM IN THE WINTER,
AND COOL IN THE SUMMER.
UP BY THE TOES,
WE GOT RID OF THAT ANNOYING SEAM
THAT'S ALWAYS
CAUSING IRRITATION,
CREATING OUR INVISITOE.
IN THE MID-FOOT AREA,
WE CREATED
OUR PROPRIETARY HONEYCOMB
ARCH-SUPPORT SYSTEM
AND ADDED OUR ULTRA-COMFORTABLE
PERFORMANCE FOOTBED.
AND BACK BY THE HEEL,
WE CREATED A Y-SHAPED STITCH
TO CREATE A NATURAL CUP
AROUND YOUR HEEL
AND ADDED A BLISTER TAB
FOR THE ANKLE SOCKS.
Herjavec: SO, DAVE AND RANDY,
I'M A BIG RUNNER.
I GOT TO TELL YOU -- SPECIALTY
SPORTS SOCKS ARE EVERYWHERE.
MM-HMM.
HOW ARE YOU DIFFERENT?
OUR PRIMARY DIFFERENCE
IS THAT WE TESTED SOCKS
FROM EVERYTHING DOWN TO YOUR
CHEAP, MASS-MARKET MULTI-PACKS
ALL THE WAY UP TO
YOUR $18-TO-$22 NICHE
ATHLETIC RUNNING SOCKS,
WHICH IS WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE FOUND OUT
THE MAJOR THINGS
THAT MADE THOSE SOCKS FEEL
SO MUCH BETTER
AND BROUGHT THEM DOWN
TO A $9 PRICE POINT,
AND ON THAT $9 PRICE POINT,
WE'RE STILL ABLE TO DONATE
A PAIR FOR EVERY PAIR PURCHASED.
I, TOO,
AM A FINE-TUNED ATHLETE.
I CAN OPEN UP TO THREE BOTTLES
OF WINE IN AN HOUR.
THAT IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND I LIKE TO DO IT
WITH SOCKS ON.
BUT I HAVE A QUESTION
PHILOSOPHICALLY ABOUT THIS IDEA
OF GIVING SOMETHING AWAY
EVERY TIME YOU SELL.
YOU HAVE TO DOUBLE
YOUR SALES
TO GIVE ME
THE EQUIVALENT RETURNS
THAT I GET FROM A COMPANY
THAT'S NOT DOING THE SAME THING.
WELL, WE DIDN'T HEAR YET --
WAIT A MINUTE.
NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO. YEAH.
OR YOUR SALES DOUBLE BECAUSE
OF THE GOODWILL THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING OUT THERE.
WHAT'S YOUR WHOLESALE?
WE SELL
EXCLUSIVELY ONLINE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES TO DATE,
AND WHEN DID YOU FIRST START?
SO, WE FIRST STARTED
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR,
AND IN THE -- IN THE NINE MONTHS
SINCE WE LAUNCHED,
WE HAVE $450,000
IN SALES.
THAT'S NOT BAD.
WHAT WILL SALES BE
NEXT YEAR?
WE THINK THAT WE'LL CLOSE
THE END OF THIS YEAR
AT $1.1 MILLION.
WE THINK WE'LL CLOSE NEXT YEAR
AT $2.7 MILLION
AND THE YEAR AFTER THAT
AT $4.9 MILLION.
GREAT SALES FOR ONLINE.
AND AVERAGE MARGIN IS 54%.
THAT'S SHIPPED
TO THE CUSTOMER.
INCLUDING THE GIVEAWAY?
Both:
INCLUDING THE GIVEAWAY.
AND WHAT IS
YOUR MONTH-TO-MONTH GROWTH?
SO, OUR MONTH-TO-MONTH GROWTH
HAS PLATEAUED THIS YEAR,
BUT WE'VE
ALSO BEEN SPENDING
THE LAST TWO MONTHS
ON FUNDRAISING.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CIRCLE
$900,000 IN OUTSIDE FUNDING.
AT WHAT VALUE?
UH, $4 MILLION VALUATION.
GUYS, WHY ARE YOU WORTH
$4 MILLION?
WELL, IT'S WORTH WHAT PEOPLE
WILL PAY YOU FOR IT, BUT --
YOU CAN GET BOZOS,
OR YOU CAN GET ME.
YOU GET BOTH WITH HIM.
THE GODFATHER OF BOZOS
RIGHT HERE.
O'Leary:
GUYS, A $4 MILLION VALUATION
IN A TOTAL COMMODITY OF SOCKS
IS LUDICROUS,
AND I THINK REALITY
WILL STRIKE
BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE
STILL SOCK COCKROACHES.
YOU'RE NOWHERE. YOU HAVE
NO MARKET SHARE YET. YOU
HAVE NO RETAIL EXPOSURE.
I-I THINK IF YOU CAN RAISE --
YOU COULD HAVE SAID THAT
TO THE GUY WHO STARTED
UNDER ARMOUR, TOO.
IF YOU CAN RAISE MONEY
FROM ANY OF THESE --
ANY COMPANY.
EVERY -- YOU GOT TO
START SOMEWHERE.
IF ANY OF THESE SHARKS GIVE YOU
MONEY AT THAT VALUATION,
I WILL FORBID IT.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
I'M OUT.
THANKS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
SO, $400,000 IN SALES --
I -- IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU.
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE --
WILL IT WORK AS
A STANDALONE ONLINE BUSINESS
FOR THE LONG TERM...
MM-HMM.
...OR IS IT SUPPLEMENTARY?
YOU HAVEN'T CONVINCED ME
THAT THIS WILL WORK
AS A STANDALONE PRODUCT SALE.
LET ME ADDRESS THAT.
SO, IN THE $450,000
THAT WE'VE DONE TODAY,
WE HAVE SPENT $0 ON ADVERTISING
OR CUSTOMER ACQUISITION,
SO ALL OF THOSE SALES
HAVE COME
FROM PEOPLE TELLING OTHER PEOPLE
ABOUT OUR PRODUCT.
THAT'S THE CONCERN.
WORD OF MOUTH IS NOT
A SCALABLE STRATEGY.
RIGHT. SO, WORD OF MOUTH WAS
OUR PROOF OF CONCEPT, RIGHT?
THAT IS WHAT TOLD US --
OKAY, SO WHAT'S THE NEXT --
SO, THE NEXT STEP IS
WE'RE TAKING THIS MONEY
AND HIRING PEOPLE -- THE
CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION SPECIALIST
WHO IS GONNA RAISE
OUR BASE DAILY SALES
FROM $500 TO $3,000 TO
$5,000 A DAY, TO BUILD
OUR BASELINE CUSHION.
YEAH, DAVID, DAVID --
HOLD ON.
PARTNERSHIPS WITH GLOBALLY
RECOGNIZED BRANDS.
DAVID,
THAT'S NOT A GOOD ANSWER FOR ME.
I-I DON'T THINK
YOU'VE DONE A GOOD JOB
OF TELLING ME
WHAT IT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE
AND WHAT THE KEY ADVANTAGE IS
GOING FORWARD.
I'M OUT.
GREAT SOCK, THOUGH.
THANK YOU.
O'Leary:
BEFORE ALL THE SHARKS ARE OUT,
DO YOU WANT TO CHANGE
YOUR VALUATION METRICS?
WE'RE OPEN TO OFFERS
IF YOU GUYS WANT TO --
WELL, LET'S LET ANOTHER ONE
DROP OUT AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
Greiner:
WHEN I HEARD YOU JUST NOW SAY
THAT YOU WANTED TO USE THE MONEY
TO HIRE IN PEOPLE --
I HATE WHEN I HEAR THAT.
YOU'RE -- YOU ARE
TWO SMART GUYS,
AND I FEEL YOU SHOULD BE
DOING EVERYTHING
TO RUN EVERYTHING THAT YOU CAN
RIGHT NOW, THE TWO OF YOU.
SO I REALLY DON'T LIKE
THAT STRATEGY.
I'M OUT.
Cuban: YOU'VE PLATEAUED.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE VIRAL,
I.E. WORD OF MOUTH, RIGHT?
NOW'S THE TIME,
NINE MONTHS IN,
YOU SHOULD NOT
BE PLATEAUING, RIGHT?
AND I GET NOW YOU WANT TO SPEND
MONEY BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO.
MY BIGGEST PROBLEM IS,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WARBY PARKER,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT TOMS,
THEY'RE VERY HIGH MARGIN,
MUCH HIGHER-DOLLAR ITEMS.
A $9 SOCK,
WHEN IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE,
WITH A $5 MARGIN, THERE'S JUST
NOT ENOUGH MARGIN DOLLARS
IN EACH SALE
AND EACH CUSTOMER,
AND THAT'S ALWAYS
GONNA MAKE YOU
HAVE TO RUN
FASTER AND FURTHER.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
O'Leary: OKAY, NOW.
WE'RE DOWN TO ONE SHARK,
HAPPENS TO BE THE FASHION GURU.
YOU KNOW THAT SCENE
IN THOSE MOVIES IN THE E.R.
WHERE THEY'RE BRINGING
THE PATIENT, AND THE
HEART IS SLOWLY...
[ IMITATES MONITOR BEEPING ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT IS HYSTERICAL.
PADDLES.
[ IMITATES
ELECTRICITY BUZZING ]
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
SO, YOU HAVE A CHANCE NOW
TO READJUST YOUR VALUATION
BEFORE YOU HEAR
FROM THE LAST SHARK,
WHO HAPPENS TO BE
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
YOU THINK YOU SHOULD DO
THAT, OR ARE YOU GOING
TO GO DOWN WITH THE...
[ IMITATES ELECTRICITY BUZZING,
MONITOR BEEPING, FLATLINE ]
Narrator: FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND IS DAVID AND RANDY'S
LAST CHANCE TO MAKE A DEAL
FOR THEIR ATHLETIC-SOCK COMPANY,
BOMBAS.
YOU HAVE A CHANCE NOW
TO READJUST YOUR VALUATION
BEFORE YOU HEAR
FROM THE LAST SHARK,
WHO HAPPENS TO BE
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
YOU THINK YOU SHOULD DO THAT?
John: YOU'VE HEARD FROM
FOUR OTHER WELL-EDUCATED PEOPLE
IN BUSINESS.
THEY OBVIOUSLY DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT VALUATION.
DO YOU HAVE
A DIFFERENT VALUATION
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO OFFER?
SO, WE --
WE CAME HERE TODAY,
OBVIOUSLY WITH
YOUR BACKGROUND,
WANTING TO STRIKE A DEAL
WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO, BASED ON THAT,
WE WOULD --
WE WOULD PROBABLY BE WILLING
TO GO DOWN TO --
I MEAN, HOW ABOUT
$200,000 AT 10%?
THAT GIVES YOU
A $2 MILLION VALUATION.
THAT CUTS
OUR VALUATION IN HALF,
BUT WE THINK YOU CAN BRING
A TON OF VALUE TO THIS.
$200,000 FOR 10%
IS YOUR COUNTER?
O'Leary: SO, YOU'VE
CUT THE VALUATION IN HALF,
DOWN FROM $4 MILLION
TO $2 MILLION.
SPECIFICALLY FOR DAYMOND.
WHAT, IT'S ONLY
A DAYMOND JOHN DEAL?
I MEAN, IT IS.
WHAT OTHER OPTIONS DO YOU HAVE?
EVERYBODY'S OUT.
Goldberg:
YOU GUYS ARE ALL OUT.
YOU'RE OUT ALREADY.
IT WOULD BE --
IT'D BE FOOLISH TO SAY
THAT HE DOESN'T BRING
VALUE TO -- YOU KNOW,
AN IMMENSE AMOUNT OF VALUE.
John: SO, LET ME -- SO, GUYS,
I WAS ABOUT TO BE OUT,
BUT I LIKE THAT VALUATION
ONLY BECAUSE
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU DO
WANT TO GET TO WORK.
$200,000 FOR...
...20%.
VERY SOBERING
TO HEAR REALITY STRIKE.
VERY SOBERING.
AND I WAS OUT ALREADY.
SURE.
John: I HAD ALREADY --
WAS THINKING
ABOUT THE NEXT PERSON
WALKING THROUGH THAT DOOR...
SURE.
...AND THAT SMALL INDICATION
OF YOU WANTING TO MAKE
A BETTER DEAL WAS, UH --
WE'RE HERE
TO MAKE A DEAL.
OKAY.
I AM OFFERING YOU
$200,000 FOR 20%,
AND THEN
WE'LL JUST GET TO WORK.
SO, I THINK -- I THINK --
WE REALLY RESPECT YOUR OFFER.
I THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE
WITH THAT --
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU MIGHT
WANT MORE EQUITY --
IS THAT WE NEED
THE ADDITIONAL EQUITY
TO GO OUT
AND RAISE CAPITAL
WITHOUT GIVING AWAY
40% OF THE COMPANY IN TOTAL.
WHAT ARE YOU
RAISING THE CAPITAL FOR?
WE'RE RAISING THE CAPITAL
TO HIRE AND SPEND ON MARKETING
AND, YOU KNOW,
BUILD OUT OUR TEAM.
INVENTORY AND PRODUCT,
AS WELL.
I'LL FINANCE.
YOU'LL FINANCE THAT
OUTSIDE OF OUR DEAL?
I'LL FINANCE THE INVENTORY --
REGARDLESS OF
HOW MUCH IT IS?
HOW MUCH THAT IS,
BUT I -- I WOULD HAVE TO
QUESTION WHAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH THE MARKETING
AND EVERYTHING ELSE
'CAUSE THAT'S A BLACK HOLE
OF ADVERTISING.
SURE.
SO, UM, I WILL FINANCE
THE INVENTORY.
[ CLEARS THROAT ]
SO, OUR COUNTER
TO THAT WOULD BE
$200,000 AT 15%
WITH A $200,000 LINE OF CREDIT.
Herjavec:
THAT'S JUST SO CRAZY.
John: OKAY, GUYS, UM,
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT --
I'LL TRY TO MEET YOU
SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE.
I'M GONNA FINANCE
THE INVENTORY.
$200,000 FOR 17.5% --
THAT'S IT.
NO LINE OF CREDIT?
NO. I'M -- I'M FINANCING
THE -- THE GOODS.
I'M ALREADY -- I'M ON THE HOOK
FOR THE GOODS RIGHT NOW.
CAN WE, UH -- CAN WE TAKE
A MOMENT AND CALL OUR C.F.O.?
UH, NO.
YOUR C.F.O. GAVE YOU
THE BAD ADVICE ALREADY
TO ASK FOR THAT VALUATION.
IT'S YOU GUYS, AND I DON'T
WANT TO TALK TO ANYBODY ELSE.
AS PARTNERS,
I'M GONNA TALK TO YOU GUYS,
AND YOU'RE GONNA TALK TO ME.
AH, I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
WE'LL TAKE THE DEAL.
MAZEL!
[ LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
GREAT DECISION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT DECISION, MAN.
GREAT DECISION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
GOOD JOB.
Greiner: CONGRATULATIONS.
John:
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
YOU CAN THANK ME NOW.
THANK MR. WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU, MR. WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU. WE GOT A DEAL.
WE'LL THANK ALL OF YOU.
YEAH.
IT'S A SURREAL MOMENT.
I MEAN, WE'VE BEEN
BUILDING THIS BRAND,
BUILDING THIS COMPANY,
AND NOW TO HAVE DAYMOND
AS A SHARK BACKING BOMBAS
MEANS THAT THE COMPANY
IS VALIDATED FOR US
IN A -- IN A NEW WAY.